bella a tutti i ragazzi non ci sono qua
finalmente a portarvi il mio gameplay di
the training signore si chiama re dei
trending allora non mi questo questo che
state per vedere e un gameplay esclusivo
ride straining due praticamente siccome
ormai è uscito da un pochettino del
training così ma mi ha detto vabbè tieni
benvenuto a me mi fai in italia chi eni
e io ho preso questa copia di questo
gioco non sto registrando lo sto
portando a questo è il seguito di the
training allora pick up a avevo già
consegnare ho già raggiunto il limite
delle però aspetta jack black
posso comprare un jet perché no perché
costa 100 mi piace io non è ovvio perché
qua le cose si pagano i mi piace ragazzi
voi non lo sapete ma i mi piace comprano
tutto c'è anche i nets lending uno era
così guarda questo delle bibite che non
posso prendere perché non oil
mi piace quindi l'obiettivo miracolo
riprendere dei mi piace e lo posso fare
semplicemente consegnando le cose e
aiutando gli altri così ma metti una
moto qualcosa all'inizio se non casinò
aspetti ci sono delle robe qua per terra
vedi che puoi raccogliere robin giro
fighissimo aspetta che voglio vedere
fino a che punto riesco a trovare uno va
in giro perché voi ragazzi questo è uno
per world voi non avete presente però ve
lo spiego questo qua è un mondo
completamente da scoprire
man mano che vai avanti scopri roba c'è
un tizio salve hanno visto un nemico è
uno dei molti nomi dicono che si
chiamano non mi ricordo che si chiamano
l'ho finito anche di essere il muro è un
va beh è un nemico e non so come si
combatte non ho idea dei comandi andiamo
a innanzitutto dalla consegna a questi
perché se consegnare questi pacchi mi
permette di avere mi piace
ok sembra 50 60 porno 66 se arrivo a 150
conterà jetpack e che costava 150 lo
posso sfidare in qualche modo di passo
di ai due cazzotti penso ok
meno male che così va migliorato la
fisica allora mi scusi mi scusi non
vorrei disturbarla a posto meno male che
non lo disturbata avevo bisogno di
sapere come dove ho trovato questa arma
e come fa ad utilizzarla perché io
vorrei avere lui l'ho fatto ma le posso
prendere qua non si può prendere una
sega porco del demonio sono cagato
addosso sono vivo ho perso tutto quello
che avevo sulla schiena ma sono a posto
allora tutta sta roba teoricamente
dovrebbe conferirmi sui 60 punti che
sono 60 like scusatemi che sono quelli
necessari a sbloccare dato come ti giri
span span span le persone c'è stata
severamente all'ambigua comunque
dovrebbero sbloccarmi teoricamente il
jet che è la cosa necessaria levati qua
che c'è da lavorare io riprendere mi
piace come gli influencer quanto ho
preso non mi ha fatto vedere a centola
in centola il ciglio sicuro ma come no
come laddove sono di quanti live show
111 bastano le cure non ho idea allora
adesso prendiamo sto coso ok deliver to
the fury search based che i 1300 metri
un chilometro e mezzo al gol
porca vacca bellissimo allora e niente
io l'ho sbloccati che si può per andarci
velocemente che sono sai che palle
due ore o vedi che il mio piano ha
funzionato quest'anno se fossi partito
già dall'inizio ci sarebbe arrivato un
no volevo andare verso lo stile dei
video io devo far costruire prova a
vedere se le squadre realtà altro e la
fisica è pazzesca perché non girano le
pale ci siano veramente fuoco prova ben
è veramente la cosa più lontana del
pianeta però perché sprint lega proprio
lui che vedo che non c'e neanche bisogno
della penta c'è lui va 19 a terra terra
terra adesso basta basta basta basta
ahia ecco a posto
oddio perché si esclude quella roba un
casino prendi e di prendi per di qua
perfetto
meno male che non è esploso perché la
visione abbastanza fragile come faccenda
salve buongiorno mi scusi lei che
pulisce vabbé continui a pulire io posso
riposo quassù cosa salve a lei
prego continui pure a leggere questa
leggendo cosa leggendo non lo so 86 live
show
prendo anche un e nei cicli nereggi
drink visto allo stub e vendo
oddio famiglia che succede sempre voleva
dividere la madonna va bene ok
chiaramente ci siamo anche comprami nero
citrin keane più 15 likes niente prendo
questo grazie ciao
salve quel pacco mi serve e toglietevi è
la madonna
su questo non si fanno nulla come
possibile dove che qua c'è uno si è
spiaccicato senza un motivo
comunque prendo tutto sto casino e prova
andare al punto di arrivo che credo sia
scusi sa grazie perché può fare quel che
vuole la macchine mia ai ragazzi
perfetto credo che sarò ma vi farci
andare quanto la l'energy drink
che non bevo l'enciclica qua sopra però
credo abbia la batteria orca vacca non
va neanche bella dritta ricercano e
realistico l'hanno fatto bene bravi
condivide trending devo arrivare aspetta
vado dove l'hanno messo sto come set
center sulle alpi ma porco del demonio
slittano fa manco dritta a non cadere la
montagna vado io a posto a posto bravo
meraviglioso come si entra si entra non
c'è un entrata ai qua fa entrare era
questo
prendi anche dove si e non c'è un
entrata in stop oste finto dove la devo
mettere questa roba o entrata con la
dietro quell altra non facciamo né
funzionale va bene e quindi cosa ti devo
cose d'altre bellissima st base
congegnate amo genio fatta veramente
benissimo tutto abitata che che arriva
dal fatta da dio
studiato e fatto benissimo vediamo cosa
è successo qua cosa devo consegnare no
no no no ma l'ho preso quello che devo
prendere che magari non ho preso niente
sono stupido non ho capito cosa devono
fare
va beh non fa niente va bè ragazzi basta
e pensavo di avere già la cosa che devo
insegnare se mi dici che che possono
andare a consegnare ce lo dice lo tieni
la consegna potevo fare niente perso
sporca ma cave dai ragazzi
direi che possiamo comunque pro bells
cene senza fatto veramente bene per
essere un gioco ha presa per il culo
dire comunque spero che vi sia piaciuto
però che il sequel di the streaming sia
bello almeno così e io come al solito
seminudo
vi invito a lasciare un commento mi
piace anche per i soci che come noi
video trovate in tedesco action dei siti
iscrivetevi e noi come sempre signore
signori ci vediamo l'anno prossimo un
bacino
[Musica]